just this Friday we learned that GM was
holding meetings at the time about
dealing with their defective cars but
you'll never guess what they were
talking about these are slides from a
PowerPoint presentation given in 2008
workers were told not to use the word
defect or defective but rather does not
perform to design and GM had judgment
words that were banned including
dangerous crippling life-threatening
hobbling and 65 others how did they even
come up with that list was it just word
association at that point okay everyone
say the first word that comes to mind
Cadillac XTS
life-threatening perfect um the new
chevy sonic crippling and dangerous
fantastic keep him going there are no
bad ideas here just bad cars and and
there were there were there were a lot
more words on that list than just those
four mentions because the banned words
include and I'm going to show you the
document to prove that they are real as
I read them they include deathtrap
decapitating grenade like Hindenburg
Kevorkian esque powder keg rolling
sarcophagus
and you're toast when demons have sex
those are their safe words we don't
technically have commercial breaks on
this show but frankly after this I think
we we all might just need one just to
get away from this story altogether so
if you'll excuse us we'll be right back
General Motors makes car is that America
can be proud of cars you could never
describe as defective or catastrophic
LeFleur gruesome potentially disfiguring
Boland sarcophagi
that's not our cars we make sleek non
grenade like anti Hindenburg's that are
a very opposite of Kevorkian s so why
not tell your family you love them and
come test drive a GM car today driving a
GM car is so smooth it's like butter and
your toes Jen
Wein walk through the valley of the
shadow of death when you can drive